hey remember when Joe Biden said that he
had never talked to his son Hunter about
hunter's corrupt overseas business
dealings
president how many times
have you ever spoken to your son about
his overseas business dealings I've
never spoken to my son about his
overseas I have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period And what I will do is
the same thing we did in our
Administration there will be an absolute
wall between personal and private uh and
and the government do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss any
of your son's overseas business yes I
stand by that statement I did not know
he was on the board of that company I've
never discussed my business or their
business my sons or daughters but I
never discussed a single thing with my
son about anything having to do with her
crane
everybody
no okay well turns out all those many
times Joe said that it was all a lie
that story fell apart after Hunter
accidentally admitted in print first and
then later in a filmed interview the
very words that Joe said while they were
talking about his business deals
did you and your father ever discuss
Ukraine no as I said the only time was
after a news account and it wasn't a
discussion in any way there's no but to
this no we never did your dad said I
hope you know what you're doing I hope
you know what you're doing I do and I
said I do and that was literally the end
of our discussion
that was it no we never ever talked
about it once the only time was hold on
no there's no but no sorry I we know we
never talked about it but you said you
talked about it yeah okay we talked
about it but it was it was just it was a
little bit it wasn't a lot so okay then
the story was they talked about the
business deals but only briefly
and nobody believed that story either
but that story officially fell apart
yesterday when Hunter's business partner
Devin Archer testified behind closed
doors that Joe not only spoke to Hunter
about the Crooked deals but was in fact
present on phone calls on which the
Crooked deals were being ironed out
a bunch of details on specific calls are
available in all sorts of news reports
from yesterday the evidence is
apparently so damning that Democrats
aren't even trying to deny it so the
best story they've come up with now care
of democrat Congressman Daniel Goldman
is okay Biden knew about the deals and
okay Biden talked about the deals with
Hunter and okay Biden was actually on
the phone calls talking to the crooks
with whom Hunter was making the deals
but
they only talked about the weather
so to confirm you're saying that the
speakerphone conversations they don't
seem concerning to you because there is
no specifics about business and it just
seemed like it was clear that it was
clear that it was part of the daily
conversations that Hunter Biden had with
his father
and it was and and sounded like most of
the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the the way he described
it several times they asked over and
over and over he described what the
weather was how uh how what's going on
on your end he the the witness was very
very consistent that none of those
conversations ever had to do with any
business dealings or transactions they
were purely what he called casual
conversation how homina
homina they were just talking about the
weather right now head on over to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you and they actually
upgrade your service and don't charge
you for it this is great news for new
and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but have not made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you'll get unlimited talk
text and now 50 more 5G data plus their
new mobile hotspot this is why I love
puretalk they're veteran owned and they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you go to puretalk.com and we'll save an
additional fifty percent five zero
percent off your first month because
they value you you that is puretalk.com
knowlespuretalk Wireless for Americans
by Americans right now head on over to
hallow.com Knowles it is clear that the
libs are giving up their morals and any
common sense I'm not sure they ever had
any there's no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being but the main
reason to pray and meditate is because
it's an obligation that you owe to God
aloe is the number one Christian prayer
rap in the United States it has helped a
ton of people maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you too download
the app for free at hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders track your
progress along the way not sure where to
start check out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year available on the Hallow
app for brief daily readings and
reflections
or pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with Halo you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
right now download
hello.com slash Knowles kwles get an
exclusive three months for free that is
three months absolutely free at
hello.com Knowles
now that story fell apart after Devin
Archer revealed that Joe didn't just pop
in on a call or two happened to be
walking by something like that but that
Joe was actually present on more than 20
of Hunter's crooked business calls wow
what are the odds a lot of coincidences
which means
that either Joe Biden has a lot of very
strong opinions on the weather or that
he was actively involved in Hunter's
business which has now led to the
Democrats latest story
which has now fully transformed from
Biden was not and would never have been
involved in Hunter's crooked business
deals to
of course Biden was involved as well he
should be
statements then that he never talked to
any of Hunter body business associates
clearly he talked whether it's not the
weather or whatever but he said
specifically that he's never gone to
them doesn't this contradict I don't
know what his comment is and if we're
gonna well I don't I don't think that's
what he said he never said that he has
never spoken to anyone he said that he
had nothing to do with Hunter Biden's
business dealings if he says hello to
someone that he sees his son with is he
supposed to say hi son oh no I'm not
going to say hello to the other people
at the table or the other people on the
phone it's kind of a Preposterous
premise to think that a father should
not say hello to people that the Sun or
at dinner with the son is at dinner with
and that is literally all the evidences
and so I mean what was Joe Biden going
to do what was he going to do not talk
to Hunter about his business dealings
like he said
or what or not say hello to Hunter's
crook friends at dinner or what not get
on over 20 phone calls with Hunter and
the Crux that they were shaking down for
millions of dollars in exchange for
American influence what do you think Joe
Biden is honest
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure you ring that Bell subscribe to
this very YouTube channel
see you next time